[Música]
bienvenidos a en 5 minutos con hoy nos
acompaña adriana urrutia politóloga y
presidenta de la asociación civil
transparencia de perú gracias por estar
con nosotros señora urrutia francisco
sagasti es el cuarto mandatario en lo
que va de este período presidencial que
tan posible es que termine su tiempo en
julio de 2021 como está previsto o
podrían forzar su salida como ocurrió
con sus antecesores
buenos días gracias por la oportunidad
yo creería que el gobierno de transición
de francisco sagasti cuenta con el
consenso político para culminar el
mandato en julio del 2021 y la prioridad
debe ser permitir garantizar unas
elecciones justas transparentes e
inseguras en abril y no entonces yo
creería que están dadas las condiciones
para que podamos llegar a las elecciones
y mantener la estabilidad política que
el país tanto necesita después de la
semana convulsa que pasó señora urrutia
el congreso peruano respaldó
mayoritariamente hasta gástrico 97 votos
esto le ayudará a gobernar o por el
contrario enfrentará a un congreso
dividido
bueno el consenso generado por la lista
para la mesa directiva porque primero se
acoge la mesa directiva y después de ahí
sale el presiente es un consenso que se
esperaría que permita que las fuerzas
políticas coadyuven a este gobierno
llevar digamos la transición
con el respaldo del parlamento
en medio de la crisis política económica
sanitaria sagasti afirmó que dos de sus
prioridades serán la lucha contra el
kobe 19 y la reactivación en medio de la
peor crisis económica cada vídeo en perú
en un siglo señor urrutia que tanto
podría ser el mandatario en los ocho
meses que le restan
bueno como ustedes saben el perú ha sido
uno de los países más afectados por la
pandemia de kobe 19 asimismo es uno de
los países en donde el pp ha bajado más
significativamente en américa latina no
entonces estos dos pilares de
prioridades deben
digamos guiar el gobierno y digamos con
un
la acción que él ha tenido ha sido
mantener en la cabeza del sector salud a
la ministra pilar master y que ya venía
siendo ministra hace algunos meses con
martín vizcarra no porque durante la
pandemia
hemos tenido tres ministros de salud y
esto es la permanencia de pilar mazzetti
al al mando del sector va a permitir sin
duda cierta continuidad y hacer frente a
esta emergencia sanitaria a nivel
nacional otro de los grandes retos del
nuevo presidente y otra de las apuestas
de sagasti es liderar unas elecciones
limpias para abril del próximo año
cuando como bien nos identifica sereno
del congreso y la presidencia es posible
lograrlo en el poco tiempo que le queda
y el cronograma electoral ya estaba
previsto por las autoridades a cargo en
el perú
las elecciones están a cargo de dos
instituciones del organismo nacional de
procesos electorales y el jurado
nacional de elecciones el cronograma
electoral ya estaba validado está en
marcha
y debemos ir a las urnas en abril para
escoger presidente parlamento y
parlamento andino
y si se da la segunda vuelta volveremos
en junio con lo cual la transición de
mando se hará el 28 de julio del 2021 no
ahí es importante señalar que este
cronograma empezó tenemos las internas
en la próxima semana y que organismos
internacionales como la oea ya han
adelantado su misión electoral y se
encuentran en el país para supervisar el
proceso que esperamos se dé con todas
las condiciones necesarias señora
urrutia nos quedan sólo 40 segundos qué
opinión le merece el nuevo gabinete
nombrado por salgas te le dará margen de
maniobra para sosegar el descontento
social que se ha visto en las calles
creo que lo primero que quisiera
enfatizar es que la semana pasada nos ha
dejado la trágica muerte de dos jóvenes
estudiantes que son bryant pintado e
inti sotelo y lo primero que hay que
hacer es esclarecer lo que pasó la
semana pasada que no teníamos garantías
democráticas y este gabinete es un
gabinete conformado por gente de alto
nivel
esperamos que pues ellos puedan mirar
con la expertise que tienen los sectores
que tienen a su cargo muchas gracias a
adriana urrutia politóloga y presidenta
de la asociación civil transparencia de
perú y gracias a ustedes siga con
nosotros en france 24
[Música]